Burg im Spreewald diese Sticker hängen
an über 30 Orten in der Gemeinde die
Botschaft hat ein Ziel Lehrer
einzuschüchtern die sich gegen
Rechtsextremismus an dieser Schule
engagieren
die beiden Pädagogen hatten vor zwei
Monaten bekannt gemacht was sich
offenbar an ihrer Schule abspielt
Hakenkreuze an den Wänden rassistische
und homophobe Symbole im klassenchat
Schüler die ganz offen auf einem
Sportplatz in der Nähe mit Hitlergruß
posieren nun sagen die beiden Lehrer sie
fühlen sich in Burg nicht mehr sicher
sie lassen sich auf eigenen Wunsch
versetzen in unserem Interview können
die Lehrer nicht offen sprechen
das Schulamt machte ihnen zuletzt Druck
und droht mit Abmahnung sollten Sie
weiter mit der Presse sprechen und offen
Missstände anprangern einiges erzählen
sie uns dann doch
Einkaufen in der Freistunde zum Beispiel
von zwei jungen
durchtrainierten
Erwachsenen ja schon massiv beleidigt in
der Öffentlichkeit du scheiß Zecke
verpiss dich aus Burg
vor zwei Monaten erreicht uns ein
Brandbrief die beiden Lehrer machen
darin bekannt wie rechtsradikale
Schülerinnen und Schüler in ihren
Klassen den Ton angeben wir treffen sie
zum Interview zu diesem Zeitpunkt wollen
sie noch anonym bleiben Schüler zeigen
auf den Schulflur in den Hitlergruß sie
grenzen systematisch Schüler aus die
demokratische Werte vertreten und
schicke Ihnen natürlich auch Schüler die
nicht aus Deutschland kommen
wie präsent die rechte Szene im Umfeld
der Schule ist erfahren wir wenige Tage
später vor der Schule werden wir Zeuge
wie drei Mitglieder der neonazistischen
Kleinpartei der dritte Weg Flyer an
Schüler verteilen
[Musik]
die Lehrer kämpfen versuchen eine
Bewegung gegen Rechts zu schaffen und
zeigen auch erstmals öffentlich ihr
Gesicht hier bei einer Demo für Vielfalt
und Demokratie in Cottbus Schule ist
meins Abbild der Gesellschaft und wenn
die Gesellschaft mit Hakenkreuzen
versehen ist dann haben wir ein Problem
das hatten wir schon mal
doch die Akteure der rechten Szene
verfolgen diese Entwicklung genau
Jean Pascal home missfällt das
Engagement der Lehrer er ist
ex-landesschef der jungen Alternative in
Brandenburg sie wurde vom
Verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextrem eingestuft dass die Lehrer
nun aus Burg weggehen ist für ihn heute
afd-chef ein Triumph diesen Post
veröffentlichte er auf Twitter
bürgerliches Engagement wirkt
linksradikaler Denunziant verlässtburger
Schule
dieser afd-vorsitzende der das da gerade
feiert der betreibt ja sogar klassische
Täter opferumkehr der bezeichnet jetzt
die beiden Lehrkräfte als die unsianten
die wurden ein Ideologie in die Schule
reintragen die würden die Kinder im
Grunde indoktrinieren und da sieht man
leider auch die Agenda der AFD wieder
alles was nicht in das eigene Weltbild
passt wird eben wirklich diffamiert und
wird eben auch zum Ziel erklärt
mit einer hetz-kampagne wird versucht
die beiden Lehrkräfte aus Burg zu
vertreiben auf Instagram zeigt ein
extrem rechter Account einen Stapel
ähnlicher Aufkleber ein weiteres Profil
ruft offen zur Jagd auf die beiden
Lehrer Laura Nickel und Max Teske auf
in der Region Burg und drumherum bis
nach Cottbus haben wir eine extrem gut
vernetzte eine sehr sehr aktive und
wahnsinnig gewaltbereite Rechtsextreme
organisierte Szene die sind verbunden
bis ins Milieu der organisierten
Kriminalität das heißt die Scheunen
wirklich auch nicht vor Gewalt zurück
und wenn solche Drohungen Menschenjagd
ausgesprochen werden dann muss man das
leider wirklich ernst nehmen dann ist
damit zu rechnen dass das auch wirklich
in die Tat umgesetzt wird
auch in der Schule selbst haben die
Lehrer massiv zu kämpfen das zeigt
dieser offene Brief an die Schulleitung
ein paar Eltern von Schülerinnen und
Schülern haben ihn anonym verfasst sie
fordern darin die Entlassung der Lehrer
ihre Anschuldigungen seinen haltlos es
gibt dazu keine Beweise keine
bestätigten Fakten und vor allem es ist
nichts passiert mich
ärgert es dann vielleicht dass es
Elternvertreter sind deren die mit denen
ich noch nie ein Wort gewechselt haben
mit deren Kindern ich noch nicht mal zu
tun habe im Unterricht die sich dann
vielleicht so fern gegen uns wenden ja
da stell ich mir dann schon die Frage
okay wenn wir entlassen werden sollen
wir demokratische Werte vermitteln und
Kindern zu
wehrhaften Demokraten erziehen wollen
und bilden wollen und wir sollen dann
entlassen werden dann
sollten sich die Eltern dann doch
hinterfragen für welchen Werte sie
eigentlich einstellen und inwieweit sie
ihre Kinder überhaupt erziehen wollen
dabei sind Eltern ein wesentlicher
Faktor auf dem Weg zu einer Schule die
demokratische Werte vermitteln soll
wenn Bildung gut ist dann gibt es eine
Bildungspartnerschaft zwischen Eltern
und Schule das ist der Idealfall wenn
Eltern dann zum Problem werden zum
Beispiel indem sie sich selbst
rechtsextreme äußern dann muss denen
genauso wie allen anderen in der Schule
bekannt sein wo die roten Linien sind
und diese müssen kommuniziert werden das
heißt
auch Eltern müssen wissen wo es
Maßnahmen gibt was nicht geduldet wird
der weil halten die rechten Parolen in
den Klassenzimmern an ein Schüler
beschreibt die jetzige Situation ich bin
sehr wütend
ich sage mal Wut und Perspektivlosigkeit
sind die beiden Gefühle die mich
tagtäglich plagen es hat sich im
Gegenteil alles nur noch verschlimmert
und ich glaube dass das mit der
rückhaltlosigkeit zu tun hat die die
Lehrkräfte erfahren haben
nach wochenlanger Zurückhaltung äußert
sich der brandenburgische
Bildungsminister jetzt zu den
Rechtsextremen Vorfällen bin ein
bisschen erschrocken erinnert ein
bisschen an Zeiten die in Deutschland
eigentlich lange Vergangenheit sein
sollten und ich hoffe sehr dass es
gelingt dort in den gesellschaftlichen
Strukturen wieder zu einem
demokratischen Grundkonsens
zurückzufinden die beiden Pädagogen
hätten sich konkretere Maßnahmen und
eine eindeutige Positionierung gegen
rechts von den Behörden gewünscht
Händedruck brauchen wir nicht also
müssen die Probleme die wir hier in
Brandenburg haben speziell auch vor
allem in Südbrandenburg müssen halt
einfach ansprechen und auch wenn die
Landtagswahlen bevorstehen und die
Situation natürlich jetzt nicht so rosig
für die
Parteien abseits von der AFD aussehen
müssen wir einfach diese Probleme
ansprechen
mit dem Weggang der Lehrer aus Burg wird
auch eine Chance vertan im Kampf gegen
die Rechten Strukturen vor Ort